ici on aménage une salle d'attenté
juste à côté on construit une salle
d'opération nous sommes au centre de
chirurgie rockland md une clinique
privée qui pratiquent des chirurgies
payé par le réseau public et qui doit
doubler le nombre de salles d'opération
on est rendu à huit salles d'opération
il y en a trois qui vont être dédiés à
la cataracte chirurgie rockland md est
devenu un sous-traitant essentiel du
réseau public oui on est dans un
mouvement de délestage des activités qui
sont première chance depuis le début de
la pandémie on repousse de nombreuses
interventions chirurgicales
plusieurs salles d'opération du sus du
nord de l'île de montréal sont fermés
cette ligne etc a donc augmenté la
cadence depuis juin 2020 quinze mille
chirurgie aurait été fait ici pour
l'établissement public s'est livré au
plus vite sens
c'est ne plus jamais revenir en arrière
parce que la capacité d'hospitalisation
ni plots la capacité du bloc opératoire
nicolas
personnel sa force plusieurs hôpitaux à
sous-traiter toujours plus c'est
maintenant environ 15% des chirurgies
pays par le secteur public qui sont
réalisés au privé vitesse d'exécution
c'est sûr et certain sens les balises
imposé par les appels d'offres le privé
ça juste plus rapidement que les
hôpitaux publics les budget les
approbations les modifications on voit
jamais un jour je
vois
opératoire la pandémie a aussi forcé
québec à majorer les salaires des
employés surtout les préposés en plus
d'une vaste campagne d embauche pour
contrer les pénuries dans le secteur
la pandémie a aussi éloigner les
patients de leur médecin de famille
souvent déplacée sur le front qu'ovide
la docteur emmanuel lüscher reviennent
des consultations en présentiel mais on
est très loin de la situation pré
pandémique je vous dirais qu'on est pas
mal
80% sur place puis peut-être 20% au
téléphone
avec une clientèle souvent très
vulnérable la télémédecine adoré
al'avantage continue comme ça parce que
c'est vraiment une belle amélioration la
de 25
dr huchet et l'infirmière marie ève
barry font un suivi à distance avec
michel qui combat certaine dépendance au
début de la pandémie les suivis à
distance sont devenus incontournables
des patients qui se retrouvait seul se
sont retrouvés seuls pendant des mourres
paris le seul contact chez nous qu'ils
appelaient et il reste toujours très
important plusieurs patients et
ouvertement j'aimerais mieux pour me
présenter présent moi j'ai peur malgré
ces progrès provoqués par la pandémie
certains retards restent très importants
comme par exemple en informatique je
vous dis qu on pas que c'est encore des
raquettes en 2022 milieu médical et sap
ont beaucoup changé ici david gêne-t-il
et radio canada montréal